it's official the folks at
dunder-mifflin are moving out as hard as
it is to hear the beloved sitcom The
Office is leaving Netflix the streaming
giant confirmed the news on Tuesday June
25th tweeting that the office will
remain in its content library until
January 2021
then it's gone from Netflix for good why
am I so sad am i doing the wrong thing
absolutely not it's just that sometimes
goodbyes are a [ __ ]
before you start sobbing into your
world's best boss mugs you should know
that it's not all bad
viewers who fell in love with the
opposite still binge the series from the
comfort of their own homes they'll just
have to do it on a different streaming
platform starting in 2021 the office
will be available to watch on NBC
Universal yet to release streaming
service the offices quirky cast of
characters and it's witty storylines
have found a place in millions of
viewers hearts over the years and 2018
Netflix subscribers spent more time
watching the office than any other
television series available to stream on
the platform so as hard as the show's
departure will be for viewers it may be
even harder for Netflix the reason why
the office is leaving Netflix is because
NBC Universal which owns the series has
decided to remove it from the streaming
platform and bring it to its own service
NBC Universal previously licensed the
office to Netflix but now that the
series current deal with the service is
about to expire and NBC Universal yet
unnamed platform is expected to launch
in the middle of 2020
it isn't advantageous for NBC Universal
to continue granting streaming rights to
Netflix according to The Hollywood
Reporter the company has secured
exclusive domestic streaming rights for
all nine seasons of the office in a
five-year deal paying a staggering 100
million dollars per year to stream it on
its upcoming platform that a lot of
guacamole a lot of green lat agree NBC
Universal executives are incredibly
excited that the office is shifting from
Netflix to the impending streaming
service with the company's chairman of
direct-to-consumer and digital
enterprises Bonnie hammer saying the
office has become a staple of pop
culture and is a rare gem whose
relevance continues to grow at a time
when fans have more entertainment
choices than ever before we can't wait
to welcome the gang from Dunder Mifflin
NBCUniversal 'he's new streaming service
when netflix addressed the situation it
took a slight jab at nbc/universal and
mentioning that office fans can continue
watching the series ad free until
January 2021
by contrast NBC Universal streaming
service is ad supported the move to have
the office leave Netflix has been in
progress for some time now in April 20
19 it was reported that NBC Universal
brass were engaging in quotes internal
discussions about removing the office
from Netflix when the contract expires
in 2021
and subsequently loading it on to the
new streaming site this is exactly what
happened with friends another much
adored sitcom that originally aired on
NBC Warner Brothers television produced
and distributed friends and Netflix paid
a pretty penny to keep the series in its
library year after year though it was
briefly believed at the end of 2018 that
friends would leave the platform in
January 2019 the truth is that it's
sticking around until sometime in 2020
when warner media's new streaming site
enters the arena warner Media intends to
use friends is a major selling point for
the new platform and it's likely that
NBC Universal wants to do the same with
the office with the office and so many
other wonderful shows getting plucked
from Netflix the platform is going to
have to ramp up its original content to
keep subscribers around Netflix has
great original series like stranger
things
Bojack horseman glow the crown and more
in its catalog but it remains to be seen
whether those shows will ever be able to
fill the void the office will leave
behind all we can do for now is enjoy it
while it's here and remember what a wise
man once said check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
that coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]